quand elle rentre trop froide je sais ça
parce que ademe blues est un dealer
marseillais
franchement ademe ce que vous rendez
compte du mal que vous faites à tous les
jeunes voilà qui sont en souffrance et
qui trouve peut-être voilà un
échappatoire dans la drogue dans le est
ce que vous pensez à ça quand vous quand
vous êtes payé quand vous rentrez le
soir chez vous ce que vous avez des
remords non non un peu parce que parce
que je force personne à venir là c'est
je fais ça demande malgré parce que je
suis un mec que je vais chercher leur
j'en sais pas j'attends d'eux pas
l'argent dont vous pensé qu'à l'argent
voilà ce qui vous intéresse et de
balades de faire de faire de l'argent
donc prendre ta paix et de rentrer chez
toi mais même si vous pouvez mettre en
danger la vie d'autrui si
ces gamins nous la vie d'autrui parce
que l'assiette il est responsable à la
limite au-delà la sienne n'est pas qu'on
s'en fout mais celui-ci est là il est
responsable mais la vie des autres voilà
c'est plus compliqué qu'on la mort ils
pas censés l'argent facile non c'est pas
de l'argent facile mais quand tu fais de
l'argent facile quand tu fais des tp de
10 heures quand tu fais de tp de 10h à
minuit des temps plein des temps plein
mais quand je fais de 10h à minuit et tu
prends ta paire minuit je te demande pas
que tu vas tu vendre le surnom mr aden
adde m aden adde m alors on va on va pas
vous plaindre adèle merci il ya des gens
qui travaillent à l'usiné du corps avec
deezer et qui gagne 1200 euros par mois
et travaille comme comme des chiens je
suis sûr que gagner pas 1200 euros par
mois a même deux fois plus deux fois
plus on est content maintenant mais il
n'y a pas deux fois plus il va pas durer
pour 2400 bras mais des fois il ya eu
beaucoup travaillé je garde tous en un
temps où vous travaillez pour quelqu'un
vous n'êtes pas votre propre patron
alors une fois dans le réseau comment ça
se passe comment vous êtes arrivé
comment il est arrivé là vous à des mois
de plus jeune je suis dedans je suis en
décalage
après il faut que chaque tour on va dire
21 ans d'accord il avait démarré vers
que la vermée 13 14 ans 13 14 ans ont
commencé à dire et déjà 13 14 ans vous
avez fait quoi au départ vous étiez
comme nordine chauffe budgétaire
c'est sur le poste le plus bnf au labo
ya plus de bénéficier à moindre risque
et c'est celui où c'est le plus bas
grade et et après vous êtes monter de
grade
ouah c'est à dire c'est quoi les grades
ben ces guetteurs wander gérant grands
gérants et vous vous avez fait quoi moi
j'ai fait que guy terrain je me suis sûr
que vous vous êtes quoi aujourd'hui
à peu près vous êtes vous êtes bien
remonter un peu vous avez vous êtes fier
de vous a des marges pour faire naître
pas fier j'aimerais bien avoir un
travail comme tous les genres préférés
préféreriez faire autre chose vraiment
bien sûr c'est je fais partie son avis
faire ça c'est pourquoi vous faites ça
alors puisque vous avez intelligent
parler intelligiblement vous avez l'air
quelqu'un doit là de très posé de daim
voilà pourquoi vous fait pas autre chose
pour vous les avez pas laisser croire
que vous avez fait quoi dans la vie 13
14 ans vous avez quitté l'école non j'ai
toujours resté dans l'écoulement
d'accord et là j'ai eu mon ca fait en
fait je faisais je faisais des genres
j'allais à l'école en même temps on va
encore vous n'avez pas envie d'arrêter
poussent à arrêter ouais bien sûr je
comptais un jour c'est pas pour la vie
aujourd'hui vous avez 21 ans vous avez
pas peur j'ai pages internes en donnant
mon gré à gré mais vous n'êtes plus vous
êtes plus mineures en tout cas non je
fais un mineur devrait donc et ça peut
être plus compliqué pour vous maintenant
on lit bien sûr mais on assume les
conséquences c'est comme ça c'est les
risques vous avez été arrêtés combien de
fois zéro franc zéro x pour l'instant
zéro je comprends pas me faire arrêter
nicolas mais vous vous vivez pas avec la
peur au ventre les deux là vous n'avez
jamais eu peur de vous faire descendre
ou les choses comme ça ben lui mon
collègue il a pris une balle dans
l'épaule et chiens avec lui ah oui nous
dont s'était affalé dans un quartier ça
ça vous fait peur quand même avant bien
sûr le joker mais qu'est-ce que vous le
pensez
vous avez des banalités on va dire
d'accord c'est devenu vous vivez avec sa
maestria c'est la stricte chaleur street
oui delphine je pense qu'il ya beaucoup
de fantasmes autour des sommes d'argent
que les dealers peuvent gagner
effectivement tu parlais environs de
2004 tu sais que on peut bosser autre
part il ya maintenant plein de
restaurants qui réouvre qui cherchent
des serveurs je vous montre aller au
bout d'un moment tu es gradé des fier de
toi tu as des responsabilités et puis
c'est secure et puis le soir tu peux
dormir tranquille vous savez qu'il ya
tous ces métiers là qu'on peut nous
faire totalement raison monsieur je vous
montre moi si l'on montre moi ta vous
avez vous changé d'avis c'est vrai
pourquoi mes bottes noires bon alors
vous avez vu changer d'avis mais l'
ademe vous n'allez pas me dire que vous
avez que la cause de votre tête vous
pouvez faire que ce merci mais non merci
non content et je comptais bien je
comptais bien un jour arrêter de santé
vont ils faire quoi dans la vie moi je
comptais je voulais être mon propre
patron d'accord
je sais pas j'ai envie d'ouvrir un petit
commerce pour vous conter arrêté con je
comptais pas tardé juin je vous dis moi
je la résume bien la situation je suis
halluciné parce que nous sommes bien là
c'est tout vous êtes dit il c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait mine de rien appris
du genre
est posée il est pâtissier qui fait des
conneries mais qui continue là mais il
dit les faibles mentalement parce que
c'est la facilité qu'il a choisi moi
j'ai grandi entre les fossés gens les
morineau la cité du luth pour ceux qui
connaissent j'ai passé 28 ans dans un
quartier égal chaque fois que j'étais
travail à 15 ans et demi les mecs ils
m'ont dit arrête de faire coincer fûts
de bière tu fais pitié viens avec nous
pour d'idées pour faire le show à
l'époque c'était mille francs mille
francs par jour c est moi je touchais
5100 francs c'était que dalle c'est en
cinq jours je pouvais faire mon moi
mentalement moi j'avais envie d'y
arriver mentalement je voulais que mes
parents ils soient fiers mentalement je
voulais garder je voulais faire les
choses tout seul est la facilité c'est
d'aller faire les choses comme il l'a
dit lui lui voulait das a cédé ça c'est
facile de le faire faut pas dire tout à
l'heure il a dit il ya moins de risques
il ya des risques de prendre une balle
dans la tête les mecs faut pas dire aux
jeunes n'y a pas de risque vient des
russes et les jours qui suivent quand je
te dis c'est la facilité il veut faire
chefs d'entreprise tablent de droite un
de jambes faut aller travailler tu peux
pas faire ça toute ta vie et dans les
quartiers il ya aussi des jeunes qui
font pas que ça qui font pas que du deal
il ya des jeunes qui vous travaillez
qu'il va sortir la preuve les repentis
mais vous rendez compte la catastrophe
18 ans il est déjà repenti faut juste
laisser loin faut de changer c'est moi
un moment donné faut
il faut qu'ils s'y mettent un moment
donné qui n'est pas à laisser vos
enfants abandonnés dans les taillis oui
il est 10h alors juste non nordine et m
aujourd'hui il ya plein de gens qui
proposent à marseille d'envoyer l'armée
on n'est pas au kazakhstan
a envoyé l'armée il ya des familles des
pays qui se baladent vont voir leurs
mines tout
changer du tout quand ils voient des
kalachnikov
mais il ya un petit kit de 14 ans qui
est mort
va pas tirer comme les les cela dit
leurs tirs à la kalachnikov sur des gens
des innocents et c'est déjà
la police